yo it up it's the kid game right here
wild 101 Idaho's party station kicking
with the only bootleg cab man who let
can't be everywhere man y'all know y'all
wondering why they call them bootleg cab
and I ain't gonna tell you is what it is
man we keeping it locked down i'll hand
boise yo it's your boy bootleg cab wild
101 idaho's party station hanging out
with hurricane game right now in the
building met and right now he is let's
see is fire hardly i'm kinda member 10
what is he doing I'm trying oh he's
blows balls I say it's 5 to nothing he's
on the new MLB 2k9 just came out today I
gotta [__] from cali the boise they
shipped the yesterday got here today I'm
tending oh right now I'm feeling real
good about myself I'm currently number
one in 2k nine NBA okay so if anybody
wants to try to get at you try to
challenge you on this man what's your
gamertag are you trying to get that out
of you dash not dash play dead me we
want to see what you think about the
whole chris brown rihanna thing that's
going on I don't think I've heard
anything come on from you about what you
think about the whole thing man I just
saw I think it's a sad situation you
know I'm saying I think what everybody I
think the point today by missing is that
they both kids man so what you know what
we think it was probably some major
domestic violence you know I'm saying
was probably just a little you know cat
and low cal cat and puppy fight man
between you know people that used to be
teenagers just like yesterday man I mean
Rihanna came be no older than 20 and
Chris Brown I know it's about 20 years
old man so I mean you know it's just
people people making it out to be more
than what it is like the media always
does anyway man I say get a kid a break
man i'm pretty sure they're gonna
probably end up back together anyway man
and whoever told her to file charges it
was proud of you man hope i can see it
right now they do Rihanna you gotta you
know you gotta press charges on the kid
you know what yeah something like that
man we yo Chris Brown Dahomey man
Rihanna man y'all stay up maybe I just
kiss and make up hey one more what's
your take on the whole rick ross 50 beef
man oh man i'm going about to talking
about the defender across i got my beer
I seen I'm growing the rick ross out I'm
growing it out man i'm bout to about to
jump in the middle of the beach man but
now i'm staying out of beach these days
good 50 do its thing like Ross do
anything man i'm on tour right now
stacking my paper man and that's just
what i'm doing alright and then uh every
last time I talked to you time I retire
and I just heard recently you aren't
returning anymore is that is that was
that can actually confirmed her yeah I
in return man I got to work on my album
man I gotta come keep giving to people
you know what a gangster [__] man
straight out of confidence going down
four albums in come this September's
something like that man i'ma drop some
new heater I even got album title may be
called I will accede games that's all
fellow